yeah but like Twitter itself was bloated
with employees as it was yeah that's
already like I think so yeah they let
off a lot of people and it seems to be
working okay yeah
[Music]
what do you guys think about work from
home you think it's whack you think it's
a hoax you think it's [__] nonsense I
kind of feel like we've been work from
home like before work from home I think
it depends on what the company does
anything what's so funny huh from home
it's [__] silly huh
yeah yeah you think it's so [__]
silly huh yeah aren't you one of the
biggest supporters of work from home I'm
rarely home when I'm doing my actual
work I'm like all over the [__] world
I hate on work from home because I'm
just envious so I like to [__] on it I
think it depends on the work and the
company that you're in is what I think
so what about Twitter what about Twitter
so Elon Musk sent a notice to staff at 2
30 in the morning on Wednesday this past
week if you're watching this uh next
November he was on East Coast time
that's March
um to remind them that working from home
is not acceptable so uh this has been a
problem for for that Elon says for
Twitter
since he's taken over the company he's
like hey work from home is Wackadoo [__]
we're we're phasing this out please
everyone start showing up the [__]
work I don't know anyone that's more
productive from working at home
than working like as a team together I
agree in a person unless you're like an
extremely high performer self-motivated
but even then that's a lot to expect
those guys in a team environment have
Synergy but Bart don't you think that a
physical trainer could
be great if he's working from home with
someone who's at Parkville but if his
office is the gym wouldn't the gym be
more effective open your mind a little
bit [__] Jesus
a little bit so like yeah a personal
trainer who works at barbell okay he's
working at home
but your person is in like the person
that they're working with is at the gym
he's at the gym he's coaching them
through Facebook yes yes way more
productive that way right
he's a real Hustler
yeah
I would also like to note that I don't
think that it's uh important information
or a fact that Elon sent this message at
2 30 in the morning that just proves
that elon's working late that has
nothing to do with like you have to come
in as an employee at 2 30 in the morning
he just happens to send that out it's
done isn't that fine yeah like if it's
programmers and do they and then also
like how distracted do they get so Elon
was noting that half of the San
Francisco headquarters of Twitter was
empty the day before so at 2 30 in the
morning he's like yo what the [__] is
going on you have to show up unless you
have some kind of crazy reason why you
you can't be here you need to be here
yeah but like Twitter itself was bloated
with employees as it was yeah that's
already like I think so yeah they let
off a lot of people and it seems to be
working okay yeah
hmm I don't know about that I could tell
you one thing from personal experience
with like barbell stuff when during
covid everyone's working remote and some
of the biggest miscommunications we had
was because we worked remote like
weather like oh like what this Swatch or
what Swatch we're talking about this
this material whatever and even if you
FaceTime and you zoom or whatever and
then they'll be like oh man this is
[__] taking two weeks this deadline
is coming up I'm like let's just meet
each other at each other's house we
literally go there we put the materials
on the table five minutes done wow and
I'm like if this is happening in this
part of the company how many other
things could have been squashed or done
in like five minutes but it's dragged
out every time there's been some
[__] that I've ever been part of it
was because everyone was in the same
place at the same time yes it's like
remote [__] it's like playing
telephones it's like I'm sniping at you
remotely because of whatever because I'm
just I'm supposing something about you
instead of like let's just talk about it
accumulate figure it all out right then
and now everyone that was involved work
it out boom don't bring a better touch
right but what if it's not necessarily
creative work what if it's just boring
data entry [__] that you don't even need
people don't even have a say like 100
people don't even have opinion they just
have to do it I mean they do customer
service from work from home like
sometimes I'd be calling in they're like
helping me out there's a baby crying and
like you know there's like that's true
there's certain things I feel like you
can do work from home but if it if your
job relies on other people down the
pipeline and you might bottleneck a
project I think that's where it could
mess it up coding somewhere yeah if
you're debugging Croatia yeah like who
cares but if you're part of a team it's
different if you're doing only fans if
you're Elon Musk and your track record
includes things like being the richest
man in the world or like building some
of the biggest companies ever I think
you should listen to the guy as a
business owner a little bit yeah I agree
with that it's kind of crazy you made a
little torch sure and it's sold out
within seconds that's awesome you know
what I mean it's like I just you know we
recently saw this other article it's
like Twitter was bought for 44 billion
dollars now worth 20 billion granted
there's a recession all that stuff it's
like there's flaws so he's obviously so
he's got to fix him
if I was running Twitter dude it would
be all okay what no one would be allowed
to share personal thoughts and feelings
keep that [__] to yourself my dad would
have never bought something for 60 mil
if it's only worth 20 mil no way yeah
yeah but that's why I think it depends
on what the company is what what you're
doing what culture you're trying to
build in that company if he's trying to
build a culture where everybody works
together then yeah like a lot of tech
companies the reason why they have so
many employees is because like most tech
companies don't make money like they
don't make profit they don't [__]
sell anything they just evaluate it and
then they get a lot of funding from
Venture capitalists that throw money in
it and then you got to spend it you
can't just let the money sit so what do
you do you go to Silicon Valley Bank you
[__] open up an account and they hold
your money and lose it I was so with you
until that last part damn but also same
with the invisible damn it but the way
that they do that's how they run their
hustle is that hey look look at our
company it's growing right you got to
hire more people you got to have all
these [__] redundant jobs you grow
bigger bigger bigger we need three
cities to come in look at this we're
[__] in 10 cities now we got whatever
right and then they're like oh my God
this shit's blown up like crazy let's
throw more money
exactly from all your shares it's like
modern day [__]
multi-level marketing it's a pyramid
scam [__] I got a buddy who's an
Aeronautics engineer and he has a team
of people that work under him and they
all work from home and it makes perfect
sense because somebody at a wind tunnel
is doing a test and they all get the
data to wherever their homes are and
then they just crunch the numbers and
they send back data immediately they
don't they wouldn't need to be in the
same place yeah like it totally makes
sense that like they're working from
home there's like things like that that
I'm like okay that makes sense they're
basically just looking at the screen the
whole time just going click click click
send it back send it back and they're
just like processing yeah and then from
like a business point of view maybe
they're not spending money on like a per
hour salary or like an office space and
desks and like furniture and all this
stuff and then when you measure those
numbers against like what they're
actually doing for the type of work that
could make sense but the second there's
actual decision making and like team
building and like other things that like
Joe said like you're relying on another
person to make a decision in order for
you to make a decision and communication
has to be in flow it's like that that's
different of course there's to be way
more effective when people are in the
same space together yeah yeah so
according to the labor department
um 72.5 of business establishments said
their employees teleworked rarely or not
at all last year
um The Wall Street Journal reported that
figure was an increase from 60.1 percent
in 2021. yeah so in 2021 the amount of
people who were teleworking rarely or
not at all was 16.1 percent so like a 12
12.5 came back in the workforce that's a
lot though yeah it's a lot wow
but there's still like you know 20
almost 20 or almost 30 we're out I don't
know I'm extroverted so I like working
with people I like the idea of going I'm
introverted and I like working with
people I think it depends make it more
productive that way like for example way
more productive 100 I can't imagine a
creative brainstorm session just like on
email even through Zoom is hard yeah
you're not feeling the emails I don't
know maybe the whole experience but what
I do not like and this can happen on
Zoom too are those stupid pointless long
meetings with No Agenda that wastes a
lot of time and that I think can happen
in like the water cooler conversation
there's a lot of like redundancies and
like she feels yeah
there's also sometimes you're in a
writer's room with somebody who say
maybe burned our SNL because of a sexual
harassment charge and like I'm just
talking like maybe like maybe this
happened generalities and like yeah
maybe their name was like let's say
shimmerys
and you're in a writer's room with them
and you're pitching stuff but it's
almost like they're working from home
because they're not even really there if
they're kind of on their iPad the whole
time but then you're oh the whole room's
pitching stuff but then
he's just kind of like looking at his
iPad going like
that's cool you know that is that is
that productive I guess is my question I
don't think so or would you guys do you
guys think that
um do you guys think that government or
city employees uh do you think we should
have a say if they have to go to work or
work from home oh [__] you know what's
crazy I was just up in Sacramento
and So Silent Mike is from there which
is a big you know like government type
City he was saying so originally like
their Capitol building is so full that
they lease like almost quarter mile
blocks outside all of those Office
Buildings are all for government workers
yeah but now since everyone works remote
all of those buildings are now empty but
the tax dollars are still paying for all
the leases they got to go to work I was
like that's a [__] conundrum I'm like
holy [__] like if your tax dollars are
paying for these people to work do you
think that's like kind of a cop-out if
they all get to stay home and because
it's already bad enough when city
employees are not monitored they end up
[__] around like we see that so much
on these specials you know yeah like
it's a little bit weird when they can't
be they can't be fired yeah we don't
know what the [__] they're doing they
can be caught on [__] Chris Hansen's
like getting pizza to some 12 year old
and they're still employed yeah like the
animal Control Department got a like a
big bus because they were all just like
writing fake invoices for all this work
they were doing but they would just go
to the gym chill in their car yeah and
they would just ride all these huge ass
like for tons of money they're like oh I
handled this today I had eight 18 calls
so many opossums today yeah I had 13
raccoons this week how do you even audit
the government though because if the
government's supposed to like audit
themselves that's like the cop going
through an internal investigation of
their own Department with their own
homies which doesn't happen thank God
even in that in that case they went to
all the like 18 dudes that were doing
that and then they go who's their
supervisor they go to that lady she's
doing it too they go to the person above
her she's doing it too so it's like when
does it stop yeah I would too not the
president DMV got just shut down because
the corruption was too deep it was a
great DMV that's where I got my license
from if the government is able to audit
themselves businesses should be able to
say how much taxes they have to pay
thank you
we do do that but then they go Julie you
might be wrong yeah I think I owe a
dollar imagine lying about work and
you're not even working from home you're
going out and working and you're still
lying so if you're just not leaving your
house in that way isn't there a judge
who was like yeah did build all these
hours against the city like I've been
judging all the time that girl yeah I've
been judging and judging and judging it
was that woman that said she'd done all
these cases and did all these things I'm
like hey we have you on video like not
judging what is she doing eating lunch
yeah dude she's going to Sbarro and [__]
and she's like find the bar real New
York Pizza [__] that's the biggest crime
of all that's what got her actually dead
or rights it's a Subaru camera and maybe
uncovered the other not judging stuff
they were pissed about that like that's
not authentic New York I saw that too
that was crazy authentic Italy pizza
dude she was robbing the city it was
nuts so borrow check it out
[Music]
thank you